oh Magnus played Hans do I dare look at
the Magnus versus Hans game let's see
ooh is a draw wow Magnus versus Hans
99.9% and
99.8% accuracy interesting I feel like
that's
fitting let's see let's do some reaction
is this the first time Hans and Magnus
have played since since sinkfield
cup
please correct me if I'm wrong but I
think this is the first time they've
played like just any game like online or
in
person since they're uh yeah Infamous
singfield Cup
game which Hans did win so Magnus uh not
not falling to Hans twice in a
row so Magnus plays a Spanish oh it's a
real opening
Berlin ah it's one of these like more
symmetrical Berlin
lines Hans just finished sh steel so
he's probably like decently
sharp he feing KS his Knight to play
Bishop F5 yeah nice idea to
neutralize yeah honestly not the most
exciting
game like very symmetrical
structure Magnus has a little bit of
pressure did Magnus miss a fork oh kn
six walks into Queen takes
F6 and then Hans would be winning
because oh no my queen but then
Checkmate so Magnus did not fall for
that no ambulances had to be
called he took on E8 ah he just
simplifies into the King Pawn ending
that's so funny so they're they're on
move
and this is not even this is about
onethird of the game not even halfway oh
this is really funny okay I'll show the
notation after I finished but basically
what happened is they just moved around
forever and the longer they move
around I think the higher the accuracy
will go cuz all of these moves are 100%
accuracy someone call
a
statistician very suspicious
play so the funny
[Music]
thing uh
here the game ended in a draw because on
move
47 they had this
position after King
F7 and then on move
69 they had the same position
again
nice and then on
move I mean move
87 they had the same position for a
third
time yeah this is one of these things
that uh three-fold repetition doesn't
happen or doesn't have to happen in like
three moves in a row it can happen over
the course of many
moves so okay um perfect accuracy from
from both players basically again not
the most exciting game but maybe this
game will be farmed for content